his premise is right that basically the
more men see content like this and
realize that one the value of women is
down which I mean come on men kind of
realize this anyway but two that like
when there's more Alternatives like
there's AI Bots or whatever I wonder if
men like chasing female validation I
honestly don't see it getting better
unfortunately maybe this type of content
will help but I'm just thinking out loud
will the the price or like the the
benefit of female validation go down in
the next couple of years and will more
men wise up or will more men I guess men
are logical I think when they see their
grandpa and their fathers get screwed
over by the same system and the same
women they might